Founder Office: Hello, good name.
Suresh: Good night, man. Good dunker.
Founder Office: Okay, good.
Suresh: V gate to zen in.
Founder Office: So…
Founder Office: Is that?
Founder Office: karlevan na.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Adri, I can correct me.
Founder Office: Have you heard it.
Suresh: I work… got the homework done, and…
Founder Office: Adebana, okay?
Suresh: - right.
Founder Office: Okay, I'm good.
Founder Office: Oh, it is Hangwan yan.
Suresh: Radhati case again in Qatar?
Founder Office: kara na kara.
Founder Office: If I say, oh…
Founder Office: Okay, mametar product share.
Suresh: Hit out.
Founder Office: Balamo.
Founder Office: Unknown.
Suresh: of…
Suresh: Until.
Founder Office: You bet.
Suresh: tuition.
Founder Office: turn.
Suresh: Folk?
Founder Office: Aw.
Suresh: Hin… hinter?
Founder Office: In. In.
Founder Office: Okay.seh.
Founder Office: Wie heist die kartse.
Suresh: What do I…
Founder Office: Oto is… Unter dem Tepis.
Founder Office: Tisch.
Suresh: You have to update.
Founder Office: under the carpet. Okay? O tau ist undem Tepezhwaru. Hindadi ki radih.
Suresh: Hey, good man, Dr. Kissan?
Founder Office: Native case again, Tianone.
Founder Office: Trust me.
Founder Office: Tamai.
Founder Office: warist?
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: Ja.
Founder Office: what is… native place ke.
Founder Office: They're not there.
Founder Office: sekeh.
Founder Office: ke seh.
Suresh: DM been on it?
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: Unter DMTP.
Founder Office: Yeah.ke.
Founder Office: Yes, I can play a sickest tan, yeah? I have the same.
Founder Office: Voiced or toe?
Founder Office: randone.
Suresh: -
Suresh: In…
Founder Office: Yeah, wash machine… washing machine. Wash machine.
Founder Office: Tulene and the in.
Suresh: In… in…
Founder Office: Otto is?
Suresh: So, it's in their washing machine.
Founder Office: Wash machine.
Suresh: Washing machines.
Founder Office: Wash machine, okay.
Founder Office: in their washing machine. Yeah, yeah, in a washing machine category.
Founder Office: mein.
Founder Office: Okay? i mama, vo.
Suresh: uk esoter.
Suresh: panati na gela.
Founder Office: ka gana.
Suresh: No. Okay.
Founder Office: hai.
Founder Office: segan ka.
Founder Office: I'm delivered.
Founder Office: Okay. Okay?
Founder Office: otoeist.
Founder Office: Okay? Ka hari daruan sahan.
Founder Office: Bugalang okay there.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: theena.
Suresh: setting.
Founder Office: I'm sorry, article, sorry.
Suresh: There…
Founder Office: tienne.
Suresh: No, behind. Peace Bacini.
Founder Office: Behind,
Founder Office: Behind the adiabic army?
Suresh: Hayden.
Founder Office: winter, yeah?
Founder Office: i.
Suresh: into them cool sharks.
Founder Office: Damn Kirschang, perfect, so what?
Founder Office: Okay?
Suresh: Photoist?
Suresh: hinted them firsthand.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: 8.
Founder Office: aka.
Founder Office: Is Sirhain.
Suresh: Neben ganadale.
Founder Office: ka na ka
Founder Office: CBD's gonna cut now?
Founder Office: 4, then… So, it got a 4 dim fernseh, eta na fancy article.
Founder Office: Okay?
Suresh: Yeah, fantastic.
Founder Office: OTO is?
Suresh: Oh, babe. Yeah.
Suresh: Oh, definitely.
Founder Office: urgency.
Founder Office: The Romen.
Founder Office: preposcheni ko hagano.
Suresh: Side the evening.
Suresh: I can name it.
Founder Office: eta kudo praise.
Suresh: No, it's name?
Founder Office: One is the Panimari.
Founder Office: oto is…
Founder Office: Name Computer. Photo is named and name computer.
Suresh: Auto,
Founder Office: Yeah, computer, yeah? Auto is name and name, computer.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: to pass it?
Founder Office: pudak para.
Suresh: Village?
Founder Office: I was like… Okay, talk about a no-man's favor, baby.
Suresh: ADF or another one?
Founder Office: there.
Suresh: booking a PDF, napda.
Founder Office: book…
Suresh: Sorry, you can't me.
Founder Office: kut thiana.
Founder Office: the na.
Suresh: Oh.
Founder Office: Okay.ne, dapatihada ha
Founder Office: Bernika, number 7.
Founder Office: eti enma?
Founder Office: kila.
Founder Office: Mukhat.
Suresh: Patrick?
Founder Office: magazines, Sangra.
Suresh: Amazing.
Founder Office: keela.
Founder Office: Yes.
Suresh: Toto is dead. Toto is…
Founder Office: Sushin, yeah, Sushin.
Founder Office: Joyce, switching.
Suresh: Then, side-shifting.
Founder Office: Yeah, otoysweischen den, seizureten. Otoine, magazine satirene, otoy Swissen den, seismen.
Founder Office: voice doto.
Suresh: Mmm.
Suresh: Isn't be.
Founder Office: microwave wicker.
Founder Office: microwave?
Suresh: It's a couple hundred days.
Founder Office: Yeah, in ne.
Suresh: Microwave a U.
Founder Office: microwave kehaling.
Suresh: You bet.
Founder Office: Kiyama.
Suresh: The clip.
Suresh: Auto ist, Juber der Microwave.
Founder Office: Yeah, over there, micro, okay?
Suresh: Go ahead.
Founder Office: Autoist? Yeah. Otoista microwavele. Oto in microwave.
Founder Office: Toria.
Suresh: Mahalo, Daniel.
Founder Office: Vahalei uday.
Founder Office: auske lia.
Founder Office: voiced oto kiwama.
Founder Office: Otto is… Oof.
Suresh: Oh.
Founder Office: mea.
Founder Office: toe.
Suresh: E.
Founder Office: auof keela.
Founder Office: ka.
Founder Office: kri.
Suresh: Don't.
Founder Office: DRD ordered us.
Suresh: Egreene, D.
Suresh: Nila.
Founder Office: h, okay?
Founder Office: Gut?
Founder Office: woh ye lah.
Suresh: Whoa.
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: I never, I never woke.
Founder Office: padekut samange.
Founder Office: Yeah, it is.
Suresh: Pedigm. Okay.
Founder Office: Voice totoo.
Founder Office: Oh, para beneath totoo.
Suresh: Tepisch.
Founder Office: they already ordered us.
Suresh: I do.
Suresh: and…
Founder Office: Y langre demean voiced auto.
Suresh: Autoist, in their, washing machine.
Founder Office: Right.
Suresh: The film machine.
Founder Office: Okay, yeah, Ruan sahaan agala tat kiya. Okay? Oto.
Founder Office: Quedin neutro.
Founder Office: Okay, eta kar tunini kum kadapiga ni prepares tokilahua ma, Saman malika nagamanne dih, sahan mehikaman. Tuan kum mende.
Founder Office: Atakan puladuan.
Founder Office: Okay.i ko.
Suresh: on…
Founder Office: Ande lamp.
Founder Office: No mafia.
Suresh: Inter.
Suresh: Sorry, hinter, hinter.
Founder Office: hint kershan.
Suresh: I'm a good solution.
Founder Office: Kershank, okay?
Founder Office: voiced oto.
Suresh: Auto East for Dame, fencing.
Founder Office: Yeah, auto…
Suresh: Appreciate you.
Founder Office: Funzeh, okay?
Suresh: here.
Founder Office: Auto… yeah. Autoist for the infernier.
Founder Office: Okay… Next… Number 6, Voice Toto.
Suresh: Auto is, neighbor, name, computer.
Founder Office: Yeah, auto is name and name computer. Oto in a computer ke langar, okay?
Suresh: Good.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Odo East, suycin.
Suresh: Saidi?
Founder Office: Side-shifting, yeah, side-shifting.
Suresh: I just…
Founder Office: karame.
Founder Office: No matter a voice doto.
Suresh: Otto… Otto is, you bet.
Suresh: Yeah. Micro available.
Founder Office: Microbella, okay? Ubadeh microbella, okay?
Suresh: Auto East, auf… Dame dash.
Founder Office: Yeah, okay.
Founder Office: On the roof, okay? Otoist.
Suresh: Thanks, guys.
Founder Office: of Lemda.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: pada.
Founder Office: aka.
Founder Office: Ne…
Founder Office: keta.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: Okay, chicken nur.
Founder Office: a.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Yeah, they're there.
Founder Office: educ enema.
Founder Office: bidakka.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: Anna Bei, yeah?
Suresh: Game… Ha-anger… Hangen Laufen.
Suresh: Mmm… Leegan?
Founder Office: Hmm?
Suresh: legal. Common. Sign, sits in.
Suresh: Stehan Stalin.
Founder Office: Still in. Still in. Still in. Okay.
Suresh: Good. Yeah.
Founder Office: be kung.
Founder Office: Okay, Inagar Devani, Kathy Anima.
Founder Office: Bebegum fun ana.
Founder Office: bidakhm.
Suresh: neither.
Founder Office: akwein namaha.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Bidapa.
Founder Office: fun ana be.
Suresh: Okay.
Suresh: Be vegan.
Founder Office: Hi, I'm doing it.
Founder Office: Oh.
Suresh: Nope.
Founder Office: Good indeed.
Founder Office: Oh, maybe I don'.
Suresh: anyway.
Founder Office: kilomarende.
Suresh: for this?
Founder Office: hari.
Suresh: get an egg, a kind of bigger gum.
Founder Office: Yeah, sits.
Suresh: na.
Founder Office: Laufen kennel.
Founder Office: to put it? Oh.
Suresh: Unbelievable.
Founder Office: Ilagrek mukada.
Suresh: Excuse me.
Founder Office: Can I please sit down, Kianika?
Founder Office: Sit down VNETA.
Suresh: I'm gonna start sooner.
Suresh: Yes.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: This is true.
Founder Office: It's been…
Suresh: Anyone?
Founder Office: Oh, seh ka anime, seh set sun keys rear na. Okay?
Founder Office: Yeah.
Suresh: Steven.
Founder Office: Yeah, stehen. To stein kian, yeah?
Suresh: I don't know.
Founder Office: Che necamocade.
Suresh: Take a baby, can…
Founder Office: Negative.
Founder Office: It's a good?
Suresh: Stalein.
Founder Office: Esthtelin.
Founder Office: Ape, ape action.
Suresh: I'm not gonna. Alright.
Founder Office: Oh, api… moment.
Founder Office: be.
Suresh: Beautiful.
Founder Office: Okay, baby gungfun ana habe.
Founder Office: Okay, Ilangar Teh?
Founder Office: ganah.
Suresh: Sign?
Founder Office: Sorry. Yeah?
Founder Office: Behind.
Founder Office: Yeah, it's okay.
Founder Office: Hengan. Hengan can do hang, yeah? Yeah?
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: hain.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Sitch Ligen?
Suresh: Oh.
Suresh: Sicily.
Founder Office: at the agreement.
Founder Office: It depends.
Founder Office: hangar nika kahaina beigo.
Founder Office: Comment on the team.
Suresh: Legion?
Founder Office: aka.
Suresh: Oh my goodness.
Founder Office: Oh, baby.
Founder Office: Be keela.
Suresh: Oh, okay.
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: karma mein, mentiene pre questions.
Founder Office: Okay… se ka.
Founder Office: What kind of the Philippine is?
Founder Office: Julian Ma?
Suresh: Yulia. Julian Novka.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: Julian marked INF.
Suresh: It was one spot.
Founder Office: Party. Okay. Party.
Founder Office: The party bacon.
Suresh: Can you tell me?
Suresh: 9 o'er.
Founder Office: Okay. Yes, Istein?
Suresh: Yes, East, S, phone, over.
Founder Office: Do it.
Founder Office: October?
Suresh: Sorry, sorry. After the first dish.
Founder Office: Permanent?
Suresh: No.
Suresh: Aber nicht East.
Suresh: 4x8…
Founder Office: Oh, merited.
Suresh: Nice.
Founder Office: kuddy.
Founder Office: Birthday party, guys.
Suresh: It goes to Bucky.
Founder Office: the patanga ne.
Suresh: 9, no. Nomadic.
Founder Office: Okay, Namid Patangar.
Suresh: Yes.
Founder Office: Estes?
Suresh: I go… then…
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: the melam.
Founder Office: to hide.
Founder Office: I've been… Nothing is prepared, yeah?
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Yeah.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: The animal, one pathetic airway.
Founder Office: The cigaretteen.
Founder Office: I'll be…
Suresh: Fourth mode.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: Di cigaretteen ligand auf dem Borden, yeah? Cigarettes denima flowke, on the flow kinika, yeah? Die cigaret ligand, auf dem Borden. Cigarettes denima, fluikey.
Founder Office: hide.
Suresh: It's a good day.
Founder Office: sigaratal.
Founder Office: Woli Gandhi zigaratan, koi.
Suresh: figure it out.
Founder Office: zigaraten.
Founder Office: kada anava.
Founder Office: se keen.
Founder Office: Do you seeker at 10?
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: Hey, everyone?
Founder Office: cigaraten.
Founder Office: English sublad.
Founder Office: Yulian cigarettes danuma. Yulian make this cigarettan in dishw blood.
Founder Office: Okay, what happened freshly every day.
Founder Office: Wohin.
Founder Office: Julia?
Founder Office: D?
Suresh: Wardian… oh, Woody?
Suresh: Shit.
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: me tena…
Suresh: I finished.
Founder Office: the nama.
Founder Office: case.
Founder Office: in the shoe bladder.
Founder Office: utradehne.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: ke hai.
Suresh: Oh, I did.
Founder Office: wok yenek.
Suresh: Okay.
Founder Office: Sidi.
Suresh: Yeah, no problem.
Founder Office: wo hin keela.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: -Oh.
Founder Office: Yeah, itu kotapi itna wohin ya e va mu karna thing, gana pi kata aka, tokare din neat if case kara no.
Founder Office: Yeah, there is that.
Suresh: How are you ready?
Suresh: hula.
Founder Office: describe oh, we discussed karate.
Suresh: Oh, alright.
Founder Office: a mana.
Founder Office: utter den.
Founder Office: Yeah?
Founder Office: champagne bottle agar ma.
Founder Office: Look at the proportion.
Suresh: Enabled.
Founder Office: Nabin.
Founder Office: Dembit. The second pleasure is Naben Dembe bit.
Founder Office: Yeah, please take my shares.
Founder Office: Di sekta shaisne bandan bench, okay? Yeah.
Suresh: Calling it up, yeah.
Founder Office: Julian Stead?
Suresh: Just kidding.
Founder Office: Yes, sir.
Founder Office: Yeah, I say, because…
Founder Office: Oh, yeah, ask kar no saikmenta mein the ka.
Founder Office: Oh, ane, meta nape, wohin.
Suresh: You're safe.
Founder Office: tiuna.
Suresh: again… going.
Founder Office: or…
Suresh: Frijika.
Founder Office: Oh, it…
Suresh: Mario.
Founder Office: Neh, ne.
Suresh: Better, ma'am.
Founder Office: a little bit.
Suresh: T, T…
Founder Office: Makande?
Suresh: Neben.
Founder Office: Tanak.
Founder Office: It could happen.
Founder Office: dissekasha, Danone .
Suresh: Hmm.
Founder Office: In… in Kilada, mah.
Suresh: Anyone?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Nope.
Founder Office: Indian Kershank, yeah.
Suresh: anything.
Founder Office: Okay? Yulian state di sect flasher.
Suresh: Right.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: I'll be a good.
Founder Office: karagana.
Suresh: Mmm…
Founder Office: for Dak Balanda.
Founder Office: Gandapoli, Suresh.
Suresh: Whatever.
Founder Office: Okay, Etugar put that balance.
Suresh: excuse me.
Founder Office: ragan desalah.
Founder Office: Le Cannar.
Founder Office: ahanne.
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: hand raised karano ki vera karina.
Founder Office: Okay, since Harida Katya.
Suresh: Hey, good.
Founder Office: Good morning.
Suresh: resign for our state, neighbourne.
Suresh: Yeah, it's kind of.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: Yes.
Founder Office: tienen.
Suresh: Never longer than…
Suresh: That's really cool.
Founder Office: luang.
Founder Office: Feels turquo.
Founder Office: Sign 5, AND.
Suresh: Mr.
Founder Office: kumangana pulla.
Founder Office: wohin keela.
Founder Office: Okay? Eho para tamae, aku satifka anuna mu karena price se gagane. Kaikke.
Founder Office: Okay. It passesityanama.
Founder Office: Get leaked.
Founder Office: Yeah, I mean?
Suresh: Alex.
Founder Office: hide.
Founder Office: Get ready. Auf ke lia.
Founder Office: How damn tipis.
Founder Office: in.
Founder Office: Belen.
Suresh: How's being…
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: There you go.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: vehicle.
Founder Office: mende.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Suresh: Indones.
Founder Office: Debutche Ligen.
Founder Office: In.
Founder Office: langarte.
Founder Office: Rwan.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: in them.
Founder Office: In Dame Simon. Indem Sima.
Founder Office: toilet papers, yeah?
Suresh: 4 billion?
Founder Office: hyena?
Founder Office: Coffee, coffee, coffee, coffee, cinema.
Suresh: Either way, okay.
Suresh: So, damn.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: computer.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: shrie.
Founder Office: code name computer order, name and name computer. Codame computer order, name and name computer, okay? Copy.
Founder Office: Okay, Idah says, Blumen Legal.
Founder Office: Blumen ligand microbella.
Founder Office: Brumen legal microwaveleh.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: too late.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: in their…
Suresh: In… yeah.
Founder Office: Blumen ligand in their microbella.
Founder Office: Di microweh ka binasana dea vidhata. Blumen ligand in der micro. Blumen ligand inde microveler. Okay?
Founder Office: Multina Microbellicate.
Founder Office: Okay, elongate.
Founder Office: They're pullover hangs.
Founder Office: jaika.
Suresh: Elena.
Founder Office: Yeah. Sorry.
Suresh: Sweeting.
Founder Office: question.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Uber limp.
Founder Office: Tivlin.
Founder Office: Yeah, itepa se 10ma numerat se negar.
Founder Office: Ain top state.
Founder Office: Ende como de tiene.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: And, at the end.
Founder Office: preparation.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Oh, mi…
Founder Office: Sorry, and the Uday.
Founder Office: lida.
Founder Office: iyama.
Founder Office: Okay.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: I mean…
Founder Office: Yeah, suresh.
Suresh: Oh, okay, I met up.
Founder Office: legal basic praise.
Founder Office: Sign para at state. State can stay in, legun keela.
Founder Office: mobile phone di ka, mein se mate legal steelande.
Suresh: legal anymore.
Founder Office: legal phone ne ka kapi, the phone shop. Meh se uda phone hai keti ni tirasa terne hitinh legal.
Founder Office: stand.
Founder Office: Yeah, kotase any legal name?
Founder Office: Pressure, bottleneck of a ligand stained.
Suresh: But later.
Suresh: Stayed.
Founder Office: Eckersteel, yeah, Eckerstehr.
Founder Office: Ain vase.
Suresh: Stick him.
Founder Office: bega menasena.
Suresh: Yeah, they're happy.
Founder Office: steelen.
Suresh: We'll turn to it.
Suresh: Nika, you know…
Suresh: Chair. Still.
Founder Office: Yeah?
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: Yeah…
Suresh: Legion.
Founder Office: Okay, good. Yeah, okay.
Founder Office: Yeah. Kagatta.
Founder Office: Kashne had dan lei.
Founder Office: Khadan.
Suresh: on board with him.
Suresh: Julius. Julia.
Founder Office: Yeah, okay, at the hotel?
Suresh: Let's a good color in here.
Founder Office: bhika.
Suresh: Let's get on it.
Founder Office: Okay.
Suresh: I don't hear you.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: Okay? Yurian ko hindi Ziggaratyaan.
Founder Office: question mehde kedala.
Suresh: Julia.
Founder Office: Julia?
Founder Office: state Yulian di sekhasseh.
Founder Office: Okay. Mailang Retail?
Founder Office: mas karne kote.
Founder Office: kaha.
Suresh: I'm…
Founder Office: Rohin?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Mmm.
Founder Office: Bringt… Yulia?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Julian? Das? Das?
Founder Office: Farat, okay, Seward. Go ahead and bring Julian as Farat.
Founder Office: no hai.
Founder Office: bring to you, Lean, thus faraj.
Founder Office: Rohin brings paragraph.
Founder Office: Cash name, okay?
Founder Office: Okay, goodh, keela.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: done.
Suresh: Yeah, God.
Founder Office: Oh, ni, inghare.
Founder Office: Y lair.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Damn.
Founder Office: Jen, coming up with you.
Founder Office: garter nikkei.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Mandy.
Founder Office: Oh, wohin kame api karshnihan, itu kara inkind population.i order das.
Suresh: Julian Parade.
Founder Office: Yeah, I can.
Founder Office: Julianne brings?
Founder Office: article dike.
Founder Office: der Garden in Dan Garden, okay? Julian Brinkt, das parat in Delgarten.
Founder Office: Beauty and girino, bicycle liquor, gardening ketrapi wohini keela, fresh dinne. Akusati fully.
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: sentencing.
Founder Office: Late, that's good.
Founder Office: Port money. Port money can evolve, like, if it's a cigarette, that's port money.
Founder Office: Okay?
Founder Office: kadela
Founder Office: Okay, it is possible. Yurian saridano ko heta dah.
Founder Office: sir.
Founder Office: in needle.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: thus…
Founder Office: Yeah, good. Okay, good.
Founder Office: hai.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Wohlheim.
Founder Office: Utre.
Founder Office: Warhin?
Founder Office: Still it.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Okay.
Founder Office: Esther?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Deli?
Founder Office: Oh, another subject is Julianne.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Julian?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: D…
Founder Office: Huh? D?
Founder Office: Boucher. Boucher, they would.
Founder Office: moment, kaak vena.
Founder Office: wohin ki hara.
Founder Office: Wohin.
Founder Office: Stills, yeah?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Julia.
Founder Office: Julianne.
Suresh: Julie.
Founder Office: Objecte ka. Mukak the karane keela de Objecte ka.
Founder Office: Wohin State Yodia, B.
Founder Office: beka.
Suresh: Cheers.
Founder Office: it.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: And…
Founder Office: be…
Suresh: Do you see yourself?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: in Scripture.
Founder Office: Instagram, yeah, Instagram.
Founder Office: inskila dalapienne.
Founder Office: Oh, in plus das.
Founder Office: Oh, sudna ainski la tame prepositionallah.
Founder Office: Saha?
Founder Office: nipathade.
Founder Office: Edeke katuga.
Founder Office: das keen.
Founder Office: God, it is.
Founder Office: short format hai.
Suresh: mein.
Founder Office: In scale, I don't invert it, amai, invert it with right.
Founder Office: Suresh, okay?
Founder Office: Bosquila pep.
Suresh: hammer.
Founder Office: Oh.
Suresh: auf.
Founder Office: Yeah, ekahari.
Founder Office: I forgot that it's.
Suresh: Oh, sweet.
Founder Office: sekak dano.
Founder Office: Ans.
Founder Office: Yeah? Po, sebagigan inah pesaman.
Founder Office: auspun.
Founder Office: Anspullwa?
Founder Office: Okay.
Founder Office: Can't make it a grandebeheca.
Founder Office: Okay, 8 passes… prashny wohindala.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Will him…
Founder Office: Rohin?
Founder Office: Play.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: like, Julian…
Founder Office: Julianne?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: flow, baby.
Founder Office: Klopapier. Okay?
Founder Office: Keela, bathroom.
Founder Office: toilet papers, tiane.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: 8 inches long,
Founder Office: Oh, very good. Okay. Bathroom meke hai.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Nice.
Founder Office: hai.
Founder Office: Yulia Lay?
Founder Office: Does Clope appear?
Founder Office: Julian Lake Das Clopa beer.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ince? Inns?
Founder Office: inspired, yeah?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: In Spartan.
Founder Office: ja.
Founder Office: Badassima.
Founder Office: dishwasher aka, yeah?
Founder Office: aktiheta.
Founder Office: Wohindala?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Well, he…
Founder Office: Rohin.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Route. Rome.
Founder Office: I am for bye.
Founder Office: Huh?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Julianne? D?
Founder Office: Indiana.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: That's…
Founder Office: They are good.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Okay.
Founder Office: Yeah, good. Wohind froimt Yoliande cafe tasseh. Coffee Cup Picker, yeah? Wohin freemt jolian cafe taser. Japi uptare din na.
Founder Office: dene.
Founder Office: Pool machine. Dishwasher. In.
Founder Office: Julian Freim di Cafe Tase in kilapidano nipadapade.
Founder Office: reganne.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Thus?
Founder Office: D. D. Machina.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Neat.
Founder Office: Okay, sorry ganne.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ryan D.
Founder Office: Yeah.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Yulia, Ryan, D, Afi.
Founder Office: Huh?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Sir, in the… Huh?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: fuel machine.
Founder Office: Oshfuel machine, isn't it?
Founder Office: no ma akt.
Founder Office: keela ruan.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Bohing? Still?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Julian D. Blumen.
Founder Office: Yeolian.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Estel T. Blumen of Den Tich.
Founder Office: Okay, numan 9, ilangit kum me dapiga ne ha.
Founder Office: al-Maring.
Founder Office: kum de kiene.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Rohin, hand.
Founder Office: Hmm.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Julian Den Puller.
Founder Office: Ansi ka mukhagda.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: And then pull over in Dane.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: play that?
Founder Office: Play, lie, that's true.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: My slide doesn't work.
Founder Office: Okay. Julian Hint, then pull over.
Founder Office: indain klyde shank.
Founder Office: Yeah.
Founder Office: shellschran.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Rohin, Ryan.
Founder Office: Hmm?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Julian? Jenny?
Founder Office: Hmm.
Founder Office: Yeah, okay. Voyne find Julian, then talk.
Founder Office: Yolian rhymed.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Julian ride, then, in lane.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Go here…
Founder Office: In Kitchen Shank. Okay, good. Indian Kitchen Shank. Yurian fortekati na, kitchen cabin decay. Okay.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Oh, bed.
Founder Office: Suresh ke mankita segments Suresh.
Founder Office: Okay. Cigarettes ko headatheinne. Wo lee gandhi cigaratan.
Founder Office: Wo? Yes.
Founder Office: What is?
Founder Office: Voice. B.
Founder Office: Sick pleasure. Yeah, voice, the sick pleasure.
Founder Office: keela.
Founder Office: Okay la dala.
Founder Office: ka.
Founder Office: Okay, bicycle koteli ko headahanne. Wo?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: He's too… It's dead.
Founder Office: pushed it.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: In fact.
Founder Office: Science.
Founder Office: Wash state sign farat, okay, bicycle. Okay, wash date sign farat.
Founder Office: rapi hane.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Holy…
Founder Office: Volate, get, folate, get.
Founder Office: me dapya hane.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Oh, vegan.
Founder Office: Hmm.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Oops.
Founder Office: Yeah, Woligande, Bishop.
Founder Office: tienen van.
Founder Office: Yeah, Ilange?
Founder Office: Matrina.
Founder Office: Toilet paper still, the hanne.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Walt, steak?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: I'm…
Founder Office: Ja.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Ali.
Founder Office: wallet.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Only.
Founder Office: Flop up here.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Oh, puppy.
Founder Office: Computer.
Founder Office: Kofi kapte kapte na. Isarha.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Whoa.
Founder Office: 4K, 4?
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: State einer Cafe Tasa.
Founder Office: Kafe tasseh.
Founder Office: woke la dalada.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: or Ligon Blumen.
Founder Office: Walligan Blumen, good.
Founder Office: pullover yeng.
Founder Office: uber den Fernseh. About.
Founder Office: de la.
Founder Office: tienen.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: We'll…
Founder Office: Okay, honey.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Yep.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: Pullo.
Founder Office: Yeah, woe hang today pullover. Warhang today, pullover.
Founder Office: huda.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: voice.
Founder Office: Yeah.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: I ain't tough.
Founder Office: Wash state iron tops. Yeah, wash day tire tops.
Founder Office: ganagata.
Founder Office: na peh.
Founder Office: kayne ka.
Founder Office: mein, Tiana.
Founder Office: I didn't it?
Founder Office: Friday api continuum karam mama, adhere homework dan tenak daarati, sir, to upload karani tenti ka.
Founder Office: Okay, yeah.
Founder Office: Freitag.
K.M.R.T.M Bandara: It doesn't go nutmeg.